what's going on there reject nation greg
and john here today we are going to
watch the eternal's official teaser
trailer breakdown avengers reference
explained gonna watch this from the
channel the cosmic
wonder from our good friend warren
really wanted to cover his specifically
because when i first started learning
about the eternals it was actually from
his channel he's had some great
breakdowns about their characters for
such a long time now
that i was like once this trailer is out
we gotta cover his and he actually hit
me up this morning
telling me how emotional he got watching
the trailer and how he was so excited
and so happy to do this breakdown in
particular and i was like well i was
already planning on covering yours
because he was the
main person i learned about the eternals
from also in regards to our reaction
sorry about having to mute some parts of
the trailer post
uploading it in fact in the editor when
i was cutting the end of the video
really quick the volume
at the parts that our copyright claimed
i had a zero or one percent
with a filter on it so i was like okay
we'll probably be fine this time around
but the same companies that claimed us
for venom to let there be carnage we did
not mute it there we let all the ad
revenue go to them we decided that
we can't do this almost two weeks we're
gonna we have to mute it there's i know
it's pissed a good amount of people off
i feel like most are actually
understanding thank you to those who are
understanding about why we had to resort
to doing that this time around anywho
i'm excited to see my buddies break down
let's do it
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
this morning we just got
the official teaser trailer for the
eternals this is a lot more than the
sneak peek trailer that we got
not too long ago more than 14 seconds
yes yes it is
seven seconds long it was um that is one
minute
and forty-eight absolutely insane and
there is a lot in this teaser trailer to
break down sure so let's get started but
first reminder only seven days left in
my stormbreaker giveaway all you have to
do is subscribe to my channel and cosmic
culture to enter
this first scene that we open up on is
of an ancient
village these people look like they
might have just invented the wheel
their civilization isn't that far along
and that kind of shows when the eternals
show up because remember the eternals
are essentially immortal
they've been alive for thousands and
thousands and thousands of years
the eternals were actually created by
the celestial gods
in the marvel comics the celestials
actually experimented on the early
humans so the first humans that were
made the celestials took some of them
experimented on them and created the
eternals
from there on out they tasked the
eternals with guarding and protecting
earth and the people of earth and this
scene is apparently when the eternals
first get to earth as we can see their
ship here and we can see the people
absolutely the turtles are here
to see a huge ship that is invisible
come right in front of them
the first eternals that we see on the
ship are icarus and
cersei icarus is looking at the window
kind of marveling
at earth pun intended and sarzi comes up
and says
it's beautiful isn't it further implying
that this probably is the first time
that the eternals are
arriving on earth fun fact cersei is
played by jimmy chan jimmy chan was also
in the movie captain marvel she played
the role of
minn irva marvel thought that she was so
great that she got the main role of
cersei for the eternals now from here we
see a few other eternals and get a
glimpse inside their ship
we see salma hayek's character ajax
walking down the hall and she is the
leader of the eternals
it looks like she walks into a room and
in that room we get our first look at
angelina jolie's thena and she looks
absolutely insane
fina is the warrior the fighter of the
group
which is very suiting for angelina jolie
now in this room that the eternals are
in we can see several different things
we get a close-up of salma hayek's
character and her outfit and behind her
it looks like there could be some plants
in the background perhaps these plants
they actually put on earth to help the
humans kind of start growing trees and
vegetation
although they do kind of look alien-like
so perhaps they could be something from
wherever the celestials created them
well her character
is like a spiritual healer and they are
in the same room with fastos who is the
inventor perhaps there is something
there about creation of life that is
being imbued here
like this room is dedicated to kind of
doing all that sort of
scientific maneuvering around you that's
just kind of the vibe that i picked up
on especially we were talking about
plant life the earth
and then of course you got fast those
here it just sort of makes sense that
that room is dedicated to
helping to grow life we then see two
new characters brian tyree henry's
fastos and liam mchugh's sprite
now in this scene we see fastos kind of
manipulating something
fastos is the eternals is master
technologist and although we don't
really know what this
is it probably is some type of a tool or
technology that he's using for something
that i'm sure we'll figure out within
the first
two minutes of the movie he's building
his machine to do
podcasts to talk about the kaiju in
recent years that have been
invading the city and to expose apex
what they're doing you got to keep up
warren you got to keep up
also sitting behind him is sprite sprite
is kind of the playful
trickster of the group and can cast
illusions and sprite is actually an
adult but stuck in the body of a child
and although the mcu doesn't ever
completely just do what the comics did
we can assume that all of the eternals
were indeed made at the same time
then we cut to the marvel studios logo
and the first thing that we see
is searsie with the humans on earth
farming she's helping them and then we
hear the voice of salma hayek's ajax
saying
we have watched and guided we have
helped them progress and as she says
this we can actually see one of the
eternal's
hands create water on the ground from
here
vegetation grows so again the eternals
were created to
protect and guide the humans and it
looks like that's exactly what they're
doing from the very beginning and we can
kind of see the humans progress
as samahaiku is talking now the eternals
basically help the very first
civilization evolve and we see that they
go from a civilization that is kind of
just sitting on the rocks pitching tents
to a civilization that has its very own
city with a large wall around it and
this is pretty much
mesopotamia or since they said they've
helped them accomplish wonders it could
be one of the wonders of the world
i wouldn't be surprised if marvel kind
of worked that in there it would be
pretty clever isn't that the
ishtar the gate the gate of ishtar
yeah i believe that's what it is exactly
isn't it open now to the public dude you
can go see bab you can go see ancient
babylon
yeah it would be cool it's one of the
wonders and as you can see in this one
scene
all of the humans seem to be kneeling to
them like they're gods so there's going
to be a lot of mythology from real life
put into this movie and it looks like
they're going to make it to where some
of the old ancient
egyptian gods and hieroglyphics that
we've seen are actually
the eternals in the mcu since they are
the ones that came from space
and a huge giant ship and then help them
now in one scene we see one eternal
handing
a very like how they feel like aliens
and gods somebody else
this is most likely ajax and i don't
think she's giving the knife to another
person i think she is showing
a human the knife i think she's kind of
showing them who they are
and i'm sure this knife is going to have
a pretty significant purpose and there
was a leak that talked about there was a
tool that ajac has that helps her
communicate with the celestials this
could be it
but right now we're not that certain we
also get it away seemingly training
she's the warrior and the fighter of the
group now if you take a look at her
spear that she is fighting with it looks
like it's actually made out of some type
of
energy it's transparent it doesn't look
like it's made out of something like
solid
gold but one of the powers of the
majority of the eternals is energy
manipulation
this is much like we saw fastos doing in
the very beginning of the teaser trailer
dina also wears some sort of a crown on
her head that has a symbol on it that
i'm sure will be revealed to us during
the movie and if you look at her face
she doesn't seem to be that happy she
actually seems to be rather sad or
concerned
athena is apparently going to have a
pretty big secret
in this movie according to recent rumors
most likely the fact that she actually
has
a child in the comics actually twins
however she gives the children away to
an actual human
and she keeps them a secret
oh wicked and speed are lost again
they're not allowed to have kids
i think you know the comics they can
have kids i heard something in the movie
that they there might be some type of
rule established in the film that they
might
actually i think i heard it from warren
ages ago
they might not be able to in the rules
in their world as the eternals cannot
have
kids so that might add more stakes or
weight to the idea that she has
a kid she's the mother of thanos oh no
please no
she's like oh my god we gotta get this
purple down what the hell is that
for an option send
this could be her big secret here and
this could be what she's upset about she
could be pregnant or she could have had
already given up the kids
or she just or she just wrote good
sheets
she just doesn't want to battle weird
and here we get a few more scenes one
is of lauren ridloff's character makari
and she is reading very very fast
because that is one of her specific
abilities she is very
very fast she'd give the flash a run for
his money and as you can see she is
actually on the ship this is actually
from the same scene we got in the very
beginning and it looks like she has
collected just a bunch of stuff from
humanity over time from different
civilizations so it kind of looks like
she's living on the ship
we have everything from ancient statues
of the egyptian periods to
new lamps that actually have light bulbs
in them there's captain america shield
right there
oculus thousands of years and it looks
like for
makari at least her goal is to learn as
much as she can even though she was a
part of it all
perhaps she could be searching for
something and she has to search through
the history of the people to find out
well actually yeah her character scout
is someone who's basically
gathering knowledge all about humans and
earth and just collecting it
so that's what you see in that room
there what i learned recently is like
yes the actress that they hired to play
her is indeed deaf
this character will be deaf and mute but
they're adding the fact that she is deaf
uh
to work more into the story because the
sonic booms that her super speed creates
will not be affecting her because of the
fact that she actually is deaf which i
think is a pretty cool detail to add in
clever
now as selma hayek says we have never
interfered we see sarzi walking through
what i'm going to call mesopotamia and
then we see her in modern times
living amongst the people in normal
clothes now this is what cersei does
this is who she is she actually loves
people she loves humanity and she
prefers to live with the people instead
of the eternals
now salma hayek says we've never
interfered even though they basically
built and established civilization and
everything is pretty much a result of
them helping but we see
humanity start to kind of go at war with
each other and this is where the
eternals don't interfere it looks like
they kind of
started them off and then let them go so
i'm kind of starting to see wars here
villages being ramsable not my problem
we gave you guys everything you need to
say until
now and there are a few very important
scenes that we have to talk about
the first one is of gilgamesh and
another eternal holding hands
now the eternals holding hands is nice
but that's not what we're looking at
here we're actually looking at what is
happening
in the background in the background it
looks like we actually
this looks like it could be a hologram
or a projection of
one of the celestials after all we do
know that the eternals do have to
communicate with the celestials
sometimes
however in another scene in the village
where some of the eternals seemingly
live
we can see one of the eternals fighting
something it looks like it's some type
of a horse because it has four legs
but it looks like it's definitely not
anything of earth
now it could be a deviant i think it's a
deviant these are essentially relatives
of the eternals when the celestials
created the eternals they also created
what is known as the deviants
the eternals are basically a perfected
experiment and the deviants are kind of
where it went wrong
and in the comics they're basically at
war with each other from the very
beginning thanos is actually a deviant
himself
thanos was born of two eternal parents
however he inherited the deviant gene
which is why he looks all purple and
weird and who knows perhaps thanos is
actually the son of athena that would be
a pretty cool twist for them to throw in
there and perhaps
finish finally getting involved they
look like the one character from splice
yeah dren my favorite well i think that
is a deviant because it looks
akin to a lego leak
that i saw a while ago and those are
some of the most reliable leaks and they
first released one of the celestials and
yeah it looks kind the way it's just
crawling around
seems more deviant-like and this village
looks more druid
oh absolutely you can see it in that
earlier shot of him walking out of the
doors of the barn or whatever it's the
same
location and perhaps that's why the
eternals are finally getting involved
thanos is threatening to kill not only
half the people on earth but half the
people in the universe it could be that
or
could be other deviant threats as well
now something else to note about this
scene
is that somebody is apparently mind
controlling some of the villagers we can
see all of them pull
guns out at the same time and we can see
all of their eyes are
glowing so somebody is definitely
controlling them the question
is who can it could be one of the
eternals we don't know all
that it's definitely true what their
powers are or
it could be the villain it's the mind
another awesome scene that we
see is with sarzi druid and makari
they are all levitating off of the
ground and there's energy going
into them and in between them now what
they're most likely doing here
is forming the uni mind the uni mind is
created when several eternals come
together and join their will
and intelligence they come together and
create one giant being
created of light mind and pure energy
this is going to be absolutely crazy to
see on scene and it looks like they're
probably doing this right before they
have to fight the big bad villain at the
end of the movie
i don't think that is the end of the
movie i know that's very early on
it seems like a very early it seems like
when they're reuniting on earth for the
first time or something like that or
maybe
even when you're seeing mesopotamia time
as you call it that's more of what it
location matches up to me there because
i think druid's the bad guy i mean that
certainly seems
to be what this trailer is helping to
suggest anyway i mean of all the team
he's the only guy who gets like a pretty
sinister
close-up and reverse shot and then we
get a few scenes of icarus
and cersei they definitely have some
romance going on here
looks like they start out as a couple
and then they end up eventually getting
married as we can see here it definitely
looks like a wedding ceremony
and it looks like they're together for a
pretty long time however it does look
like we're going to have a
love triangle here because we know that
cersei is also going to be involved with
dane whitman
aka the black knight played by kit
harrington and we actually do have a
scene here with cersei and
kit harrington it definitely looks like
more modern time so maybe her and icarus
end up breaking up or
who knows then we get a pretty awesome
scene of camille nanjiani's character
who is a
bollywood star he is living among the
humans and sort of hiding
in plain sight and he's clearly made a
pretty good life for himself
kamel nanjiani actually talked about a
huge bollywood dance dancing that they
did
and it looks like they show us some of
that in this trailer and then of course
we get the
awesome scene on the cliffside where we
see all of the eternals
fully dressed in their eternals outfits
from the left to the right we have
camille nanjiani's character
kingo lauren ridloff's character makari
ma
dong socks character gilgamesh angelina
jolie astina
richard madden as icarus salma hayek as
ajak
jimmy chan as cersei leah mchugh as
sprite
brian tyree henry as fastos and barry
keegan as
druid and those are the eternals now we
have one more scene left that
kind of answers a question to an extent
i'm having which is where exactly were
the eternals during
the events of thanos we have what looks
like most of the eternals sitting down
at a table with a
very nice spread that looks like it was
provided by gilgamesh
icarus looks up at gilgamesh and says
thank you for this and he says you're
welcome and then sprite poses a question
to the eternals and that question is
so now that captain rogers and iron man
are both gone who do you think is going
to lead the avengers
so they definitely know who the avengers
are so it does seem like they were
monitoring
everything but why didn't they interfere
was there some other threat that they
had to deal with at this point in time
we are definitely going to get the
answer to that
in this movie however it does look like
some of the eternals if not
probably most of it takes place after
the snap the reason being
is because in this scene kingo who was
the famous bollywood star
has a character with him who is not an
eternal we saw this character in the
teaser trailer holding a camera so it's
either his cameraman
and or assistant this means that this
scene at the end where sprite asks about
the avengers
takes place before the eternals are kind
of coming back together and reforming
their group to take on whatever threat
is threatening them so their major
threat the one that ajax was saying
we've never interfered until now
is happening after captain america and
iron man are gone which means it's
happening after the snap
and then of course the final scene is
yes that makes sense
it rolls her eyes and everybody starts
to laugh and
that's the eternals trailer and marvel
is really treating us with their teaser
trailers their teasers are pretty long
over two minutes and they packed so much
into this teaser trailer it was awesome
but let me know what you thought about
it in the comments down below
if you have any questions about it as
well no like that natural lighting
i want a more punchy punch punch punch
and kikkity kick and boom skye
look at the sky and i liked it i loved i
loved it that was brilliant
greg likes everything greg has the same
face in every thumbnail i want something
different from marvel's usual trailers
but that's also the same as marvel's
usual trailers
i guess the big question is who's the
big baddie ultimately
that's like the number one question
that's the number one we have no idea
who the building is
i mean we have ideas it's like some are
saying the celestials are the baddies
some are saying it's the deviants
some are saying it's icarus i think it's
a fascinating
idea to explore at the same time you
gotta kind of explain to audiences
who the eternals are like we've had to
really do our best to understand who
they
were for a while and then you know you
go to the comments people like i don't
know what's going on
i don't know whose people are and so
before you can even start being like
here's your baddie
i guess you gotta start explaining your
journals you gotta really introduce and
endear us to your main ensemble
before you either have one of them
betray us or introduce yeah their big
bad outside adversary
i'm excited for the movie it looks great
it looks different it looks great chloe
zhao
i hear she's an all right director so
we'll see how it goes guys we'll see how
it goes
what'd you think of the eternals trailer
thank you warren for doing this
i love your enthusiasm and energy that
you bring to the table here
you sound more energetic here than you
did when doing your reaction to the
trailer where it looked like
you had not slept much i've never
experienced
that while being on camera to do early
morning reactions welcome to the club
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button last but not least
got a shout out a man named robert
gunderson now
robert listen up buddy you're gonna get
a classic
shout out today r stands for
ravioli because i could eat you
up oh stands for omnibus because
you are just oh you just know all things
yeah b stands for bitchin
because you keep bitching at me in the
comments
e stands for eternal like my love for
you
r stands for reticent
because you are
uh reluctant to actually just write with
that to be
here today and um and and t
stands for tingles
because you give me the tingles yeah i
think of you
and people say john's got the big words
[Music]